[Music]  my name is charles spain i've been with  fox news for over 15 years what makes me  different  with respect to being on tv particularly  financial television is i have that  insight i know exactly i know everyone's  fears i know their anxieties and i'm  trying to head those mistakes off  before they happen good afternoon  everyone i'm charles payne if a stock is  down that i told people that i like that  people bought because of me i have to  answer for it now there are distinct and  powerful trends that are impacting your  portfolio the financial media  for the most part  is out there dissing investors when  their main goal seems to be stay in your  lane because you're not smart enough to  get this break the unfair rules live and  learn i want to unleash what you know  already and then give you the confidence  to seize on it it's my main mission in  life and it's a blessing every day to be  able to do that